everybody what's going on I'm bleh and
these are all right I'm here I would Vic
and macey how did your band form how'd
you guys get together through Greg
you're Greg who's Greg my doctor claw
Inspector Gadget I heard this dude
talking about starting a hip-hop band
and then I didn't really know any of
them so I was eavesdropping I was like
oh what's he saying
that's my impression of Greg by the way
oh my goodness scooby-doo yeah a word
see at the time I was like really into
like what shoes people head on and he
had on some really cool shoes wait
what's and then you started playing
drums real good and I was like man you
know hey there you go he'll not smear
musical influences
I'm influenced by JJ johnson which is a
you know famous - from bowing inside
yeah influenced by you know a lot of
neo-soul cast like geo sky so child
right now for me it's like st. Vincent's
tune-yards then going back Franklin
growing up my dad's a big fan and then
oh yeah yeah let's talk dance moves you
guys got some sweet dance moves this
dude maybe not the move but he's got
like this stance the bass thing is that
right
[Music]
talk to me about Trap House Rock what is
it and how did it come about that's the
name of the music we make it came about
because the place and was we reside it's
called the trapper and we rock you out
inside of it you know creating tread
that's right
it's crazy tango that's good Voltron
like Voltron yeah what line are you man
you just call me yeah I did he doesn't
even know talk to me about the project
with Jeff Tweety it's sort of spawned
from like how we sort of how the band
saw it started out take songs like the
by common demyx with the 19 agency
lesbian oh just messing around with
stuff like that and so like white house
rock is sort of a project of those sort
of back of that concept almost like a
live mashup yep exactly who's the
biggest diva in the band great I think
we're all divas in our own way Wow which
means right right right that's a nice
way of saying great who could you lose
in the band second people and you only
seven people that's crazy
well sometimes I'll play with one hand
so maybe I still lose our arm or
something soft brag I like it don't
worry about it but you know I'm so good
I can just play the one hand but you
could lose me by the way I'm not a diva
so thank you guys
kids these days I look for Travis Rock
coming this fall follow my Twitter at
kids these days facebook.com slash kids
these days band you guys Rock
[Applause]
[Music]